tout a commencé sur les réseaux sociaux
avec un premier puis un deuxième et un
troisième coup de gueule jusqu'à ce
qu'on ne puisse plus les compter rue mal
propre mobilier urbain de béton les tags
qui tapissent les murs de pierre pieds
d'arbres mal entretenues au pouce les
mauvaises herbes paris cette grande dame
admirer deux parlements pour sa beauté
et négligé au point d'être défiguré les
internautes se déchaînent en un mot clic
saccage paris c'est des planches qui
vont très mal vieillir dans dans
quelques mois doit être complètement
pourri bien de l'herbe des herbes folles
qui pousse sincère aussi à tous les
chiens je vous fais pas de dessin
éventuellement on y jette sa cadette ses
papiers gras et puis les rats s'en
délecte pour beaucoup de ceux qui ont
rejoint le mouvement comme gilles
pourbaix la faute revient en grande
partie à la mairesse de paris anne
hidalgo
depuis l'arrivée d'un hidalgo à la
mairie de paris n'a eu quand même un
tournant je suis désolé mais ce dos
lanoë la ville étaient encore à peu près
propre il n'y avait pas cette volonté de
faire du moderne à tout prix la mairie
n'a pas donné suite à notre demande
d'entrevue mais interrogé sur france 2
annie d'algos affirmait que paris était
plus belle que jamais évidemment que la
question de la propreté est un sujet que
tout maire doit prendre en main mais les
parisiens le savent ils ont des moyens
pour aussi nous interpeller pour nous
demander d'intervenir au delà de ces
dénonciations citoyenne de la saleté le
mouvement saccage paris s'inquiète de la
transformation de l'environnement qui
bouleverse la vie des quartiers ces
dégradations sur dégradation la
végétalisation qui a mis en place c'est
une végétalisation dite basse donc on
aurait très bien pu la laisser au sol et
rajouter quelques bancs de type parisien
classique alors qu'on a aujourd'hui bas
des rayonnages de béton avec du bois qui
est déjà très dégradées en moins de deux
ans et puis des végétations qui sont
pleines de deux poubelles
enfin de déchets de déchets alimentaires
ou d'alcool de bouteilles d'alcool fort
tous les matins le service de la vie
devienne complètement nettoyé la place
et chaque soirée de nouveau complètement
souillé par ces mesures d'âge saccage
paris ne compte pas disparaître ceux qui
ont initié le mouvement veulent aller
plus loin ils ont créé une association
dont les statuts ont été déposés
baptisé union parisienne ils veulent
donner un sérieux lifting à la ville
qu'ils aiment et qu'ils trouvent abîmée
l'internaute à l'origine du bon clip oui
parce que pour anonymat et son combat a
été recueillie par les milliers d'autres
à radio-canada paris